make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and recently i put a poll up here on
comments explained
asking if we should explain characters
that have either appeared in wandavision
or that people believe will appear in
wand division and this includes
characters like monica rambo
and then there's also uh nightmare the
theory that nightmare is kind of like
the main
villain behind all this and he'll go on
to be the main villain of doctor strange
too and so in this video we're going to
explain nightmare but here's the thing i
want you to kind of buckle in for a
minute because this is going to be a bit
of a wild
ride in the early beginning of this
video nightmare is what we call
a fear lord in marvel comics now if you
guys saw our video
on the dark hold or saw our video on
mephisto explained then we talked about
what are called
hell lords and hell lords are basically
these beings that came into existence
when humanity more or less
imagined them into existence now
humanity's imagination ended up
basically merging with what was left of
the magic from the elder gods and that's
what led to the creation of mephisto and
people like that it gets a little wild
and that definitely probably warrants a
more in-depth explanation outside of
like a five second you know statement
here in this in this video
but if the hell lords represent any and
all
kind of like demonic based afterlife
right so like the judeo-christian
depiction of hell or something like that
then the fearlords are exactly what they
sound like they're tied directly into
fear and there's a multitude of these
guys there's something like five or six
of these guys right you've got despair
you've got the dweller in darkness
you've got knocks you've got nightmare
you've got uh kalaku and the lurking
unknown
but in some form or fashion they all tie
into fear now much like the hell lords
these guys rule
over a place called the splinter
dimensions or at least each one has its
own version of the splinter dimension so
if you guys never saw a video on like
mephisto darkfold or anything like that
the way this worked and we're not really
giving a whole lot of
explanation here we're just simply told
at some point along the line it
basically happened this was covered in
the old magic series we're not really
oldest but this was covered in the magic
series back in 2000
and the idea here was that at one point
there was simply just the dark dimension
where dormammu dwells right now this
kind of fracturing of the dark dimension
seems to have taken place
before darmamu and his sister umar
showed up in the dark dimension back
when they were just part of the foul
team just living magical energy and were
super powerful and then ended up making
their way to the dark dimension and then
conquering it right so
seemingly this may have happened because
of that or before that marvel never
actually tells us they just say
at some point along the line the dark
dimension was fractured and when that
happened it splintered off into a series
of smaller dimensions and so as a result
of that what you have are these
individuals who run these little
sections these little smaller dimensions
and each one kind of turns it into their
own and much like the hell lords the
fearlords are all
consistently kind of waging war against
one another occasionally teaming up
but usually fighting each other for
control over their area and then they
have their own individual schemes and so
nightmare rules what's called the dream
dimension
now something to know as you're going
through your travels and presumably
doing your reading whether it's online
or going through comicsology to read
comics or buying them physically is that
technically nightmare did originate in
the dimension of evernight
but marvel doesn't really connect
evernight to the splinter realms right
all marvel says about evrenai is that
it's just some dimension that exists
above the 60 universe or it's a universe
that exists above the sixth dimension
what that means i don't know marvel
never really takes the time to explain i
think marvel's made it pretty clear that
every night
and the idea of the splinter realms are
not the same thing right they're two
different places so presumably
uh every night is where nightmare
originated from and then left
and went to the splinter realms and took
over his little portion of that in the
dream dimension but that's basically it
but regardless
getting into the actual meat and
potatoes of this video right explaining
the history of nightmare so you guys can
be an expert in
about 25 minutes or so however long this
video goes on for uh the idea is that
nightmare first appeared in strange
tales issue number 110
and he was created by stan lee and steve
ditko now strange tales 110 was also the
first appearance of doctor strange
and one thing to understand is that
because steven strange was dealing with
magic in the mystic arts there were no
rules here
doctor strange was not bound by
traditional superhero rules as they were
created by stan lee and jack kirby and
even going back to the old archetypes of
like superman wonder woman batman and
those characters right it was just it
was a whole different beast right
superheroes were pretty traditional and
pretty straightforward good guys fought
bad guys good guys won
done with doctor strange it was a lot
more nuanced because of the fact that
marvel was taking an idea or concept and
giving it a physical form and then
having steven strange go and fight it
all bets were off and so what you ended
up seeing in the early days of
nightmare's appearances
is that he was stupidly powerful like he
was he was ridiculously op
so in the first time that he appears
when stephen strange encounters him what
ends up happening is this guy ends up
running into the sanctum sanctorum
the main home of stephen strange
basically and says that he has like
these crazy dreams and nightmares and he
needs help right and so
steven strange basically goes and talks
to the ancient one for a minute it's
like hey like is there anything i need
to worry about the ancient ones like i
mean there's probably some pretty crazy
stuff out there man but you'll know if
it's crazy when you see it because
you know sometimes you don't know until
you encounter it and so because of that
uh stephen strange goes to the home of
this businessman
and basically sits down inside that
place while the businessman is sleeping
and then goes into his astral form which
basically means his spiritual form
leaves his body and goes into the guy's
dreams and when he gets there he sees
this guy is haunted by this kind of like
chained specter right almost like the
grim reaper meets jacob marley from like
a christmas carol if that makes any
sense to you guys and the result of this
is that
this this kind of specter is essentially
the representation of all the terrible
things this guy did in his life
in order to get to where he was as a
businessman now while steven strange is
analyzing this he's suddenly met by
nightmare and nightmare basically
demonstrates
right off the bat that stephen strange
is painfully
under under underpowered to face off
against him in his own realm like he
almost traps him there immediately and
steven strange
actually has to reach out to the ancient
one to basically save him and then get
him out of the dream dimension
just so he can live because if his if
his spiritual essence his astral form
had been captured or even destroyed
inside the dream dimension then it would
never get back to his body and so as far
as anybody in the real world was
concerned
stephen strange would just be sitting in
the same position seemingly forever he
would just look like he was in a
catatonic state and that would basically
just be it right i mean he would just be
like that for the rest of his life right
for until his body ages and he dies
and that's basically how that would work
and so following that marvel
consolidated the power of nightmare
very very quickly right that story right
there just solidified that nightmare was
a being that could never
truly be destroyed or defeated by doctor
strange at least seemingly at that point
in time
because of the vast amount of power he
possessed inside of his own realm and so
that was followed up with doctor strange
volume 2 issue number 13 in 1976 which
was written by steve
englehart and this story basically laid
out the idea that at some point along
the line earth is totally eradicated and
so
doctor strange basically travels to the
realm of eternity in order to speak with
eternity now those you guys who don't
know who that is
eternity is like the sum total of the
universe given a physical form
as far as the cosmic entities go in any
one individual universe
eternity's a top guy right he's the
number one guy the problem is that when
stephen strange goes to the realm of
eternity to visit him he's actually
taken to the dream dimension and that's
when he realizes that nightmare has
captured eternity and nightmare is
subjecting eternity to in
just a series of insane dreams now this
was huge what had happened and even now
it speaks volumes to the power of
nightmare like
even now in 2021 at the time this video
is being recorded it really just shows
how crazy powerful nightmare was
that he could basically capture the sum
total of the universe
and then submit it to his whims eternity
is a guy that can just create life on a
whim right he can just wipe out life
with a blink of an eye he almost never
acts because there's never really any
any reason for him to the only time you
ever really see eternity in marvel is
usually when he shows up and
he's like alongside infinity his sister
or alongside like the living tribunal
and he's like
yep man things are popping off let's see
how it plays out and that's basically it
that's all you ever
really get sometimes he acts but but not
all that often but to see it being like
nightmare
subdue eternity take him over and then
you know
basically use him as use him for his own
ends was pretty crazy and so what ended
up happening here is that doctor strange
ended up kind of waking eternity up and
then tried to get eternity to set things
back to normal but
eternity didn't want to because the
power of nightmare comes from the people
on earth and so the belief was
so long as humanity exists nightmare
will continue to be as powerful as he is
and so this led to the ancient one
intervening
and actually fighting eternity to a
standstill because all the magic
wielders were insanely powerful back in
the day
and so ultimately eternity relents and
then recreates earth speeds up his
evolution and then brings it back to the
modern era right and so that was those
were kind of like the first
two indications that nightmare was this
ridiculously
overpowered character following that he
just kind of
shows up occasionally and the reason for
that is because when you get into marvel
comics
and you look at steven strange one of
the big issues that you run into with
the character of nightmare is because he
was established as being so powerful in
the early days
the only way to really have him face off
against anybody in a way that could lead
to him potentially being held off or
defeated was to have him
leave his own dimension the problem is
that having him lead his leave his own
dimension
because his power reduces it takes away
the effect of his power right so it's
kind of stuck between a rock and a hard
place do you have this conceptual being
that represents nightmares torment
individuals from his own realm
and then basically become indestructible
in his own realm or do you create a
story where you have him leave his realm
face off against people
and then in turn because he's so
weakened he's easily defeated it took
away from the effect of what nightmare
represented and so
because of that you kind of saw this
back and forth that happened over the
years in marvel comics if you want you
looked at sensational spider-man number
negative one which is always kind of a
weird number to me
if you looked at uh the incredible hulk
vol 2 issue number 81 you saw these
instances where nightmare would
basically seize control of superheroes
and then manipulate them right just
torment them with dreams and different
things like that
and it would usually take somebody like
doctor strange to step in and rescue
them now in the case of
you know spider-man number negative one
that was more of a spoof comic right so
it took like
stan lee showing up with a racket and
just like cracking nightmare over the
head
and then basically saving peter parker's
life
but nonetheless you know you kind of got
these small little moments that sort of
went in here and there with his
character but what you ended up getting
was actually a really really cool moment
that came by way of the character of
dazzler so for those of you guys who
don't know uh
dazzler also known as alison blair she's
a character that i never really found to
be interesting but there was no denying
the fact that she was
hugely popular in the 1980s so much so
that she had her own solo series that
went on for 80 issues right like 81
issues so she was a big deal when she
first came out but she was a girl that
had the ability to manipulate sound
waves now what ended up happening in
this story
is that dr doom had basically used her
or sent her into the realm of nightmare
in order to capture what were called the
merlin stones the merlin stones are
basically just stones and if the
individual had them they could make
themselves invincible that's really all
it was and of course doctor doom being
dr doom
wanted the world to bend to his whims so
you know he wanted the merlin stones
dazzler ended up facing off against
nightmare and for reasons that were
never fully explained here
uh once she showed what she was capable
of and manipulating sound and light the
nightmare just gave her the mlinstone
and that was it right so we never really
got a full-on explanation now a lot of
this tied into the mystery
of alison blair the idea that dazzler
somehow had a source of power that made
her way beyond everybody else but it
never fully tapped into it
how that worked out is something that
i've i honestly never really looked into
because again i was never really a big
fan of her character and it's not overly
important in relation to this video that
we're making
but small little moments like that were
really sort of the hallmark
of what nightmare stories were about
back then right so if you go when you
read the incredible hulk issue number
360
uh which was originally written by bob
harris and came out in 1989
this dealt with the idea that following
the death of bruce banner that betty
ross
she had essentially been corrupted by
despair and nightmare who looked to like
seize control of her soul and that's how
those things kind of played out that
more often than not nightmare would show
up
he would do some small things here and
there and those are basically it one of
the cool things that we actually got was
danny ketch
the original ghost writer being
separated from the ghost rider entity
and then taken directly to nightmare's
realm where he was kind of controlled
and
used and and that kind of a thing but
you kind of saw these these small little
things that popped up here and there
and that was basically it now something
that i want to specify is the reason
why you saw these appearances of
nightmare and even the power of
nightmare dropping off as time went on
is because marvel was shifting and we've
talked about this before in
in previous videos in the old stanley
jack kirby days it was just kind of tell
stuff that's cool and fascinating and
that's basically it there weren't really
any other rules besides that because the
nature of doctor strange was that he
wasn't really bound by rules by the time
you got into the mid-1980s going into
the early 1990s you had like jim shooter
who was editor-in-chief that wanted to
create more tangible stories outside of
things like secret wars which was done
to secure a toy deal
more or less but most of the superheroes
became a lot more tangible and a lot
more grounded this was especially
prominent when you got into the 1990s
because of the fact that marvel was
focusing on more
high octane fast paced and even to a
degree uh edgier
and grittier stories and so while you
would normally think that would welcome
something like nightmare in
he was almost seen as somebody that
belonged to the realm of antiquity right
he was just an antique character from
the old stan lee and steve ditko days
and there just wasn't really any place
for him anymore so there was an attempt
in 1994
by anacenti and joe bennett to create a
nightmare solo series in order to kind
of beef up interest in the character
where he actually ran out of ideas
on how to torment humanity and so he
took over a nightclub and renamed it
club fear but it was a
poorly received comic which kind of
makes sense because it wasn't really all
that great in the first place
but about four years later in 1998 under
editor-in-chief
bob harris you ended up having a mark
wade and andy hubert's story that was
designed to see if there was a way to
reinvigorate interest
in the character of nightmare and so
what you ended up having in captain
america vol 3 issues 8-12
is the idea of nightmare attacking what
was called the american dream which was
this idea of individuals who were deeply
patriotic now the american dream is a
concept right the american
dream kind of takes the form of like
achieving a high status in american life
right so like owning a car
owning a house things like that it's
more of like a kind of like hey like
this is a this is
a status we've achieved right a level of
success in america and so the results of
that is that when nightmare was able to
pull that off that he was able to
possess captain america
and individuals out there who were
deeply patriotic were going on these
nightmarish rampages now ultimately it
led to captain america defeating
nightmare and
effectively pushing nightmare out but
following that story you didn't really
see
a whole lot of nightmare in marvel
comics now a lot of this we've talked
about before
a lot of this is because of joe casada
and a lot of this came from joe casada
because of the fact that he was looking
to reinvigorate marvel comics
that with the the comic bust of the
1990s and marvel almost going completely
belly up that when quesada came in due
to the fact that he had helped to kind
of reinvigorate or keep marvel afloat
alongside jimmy palmiotti with their
event publications it's kind of a
publishing house so marvel could make
comics at a much cheaper rate than they
normally would if they just hired
everybody in-house
uh because joe casada in doing that was
brought on as editor-in-chief he brought
in guys like brian michael bendis and
craig kyle chris yost with reminder
a lot of these a lot of these writers
like matt fraction who helped to
reinvigorate marvel in the the early to
mid
and even late 2000s really over this
10-year period stretching from 2001 to
2010
and so the idea was let's go back to the
drawing board right just get rid of all
these unnecessary things that's why you
got stories like house of m where the
mutant population was reduced down to
198 when scarlet witch basically took
away
98 of the mutant population's powers
that's why you got spider-man one more
day when the marriage between peter
parker and mary jane watson was
nullified
and treated as though it never existed
uh that's why you got things in the
aftermath of civil war
you got brand new day which is where
doctor strange wiped the world's
knowledge of the fact that peter parker
was spider-man when he revealed his
identity during the civil war event
that's where he got a lot of those
things from right civil war you got dark
rain you got siege you got a lot of
stuff
that was designed to kind of rework
marvel from the ground up and make
things a lot simpler and easier to
understand and so there wasn't really
any room for nightmare because nightmare
was kind of just this contextual guy
that existed out there and so you did
get a little bit of
involvement with hercules in the god
squad that came from secret invasion but
the the most notable
thing that actually happened with
nightmare was it was only really
relevant if you knew his history but it
came during chaos war which is a story
that we've actually covered where the
chaos king went through and effectively
killed
almost all the gods and cosmic entities
that existed out there in marvel comics
now the idea was that traveling to the
realm of nightmare
and killing nightmare in and of itself
was pretty impressive but the result of
this is that because nightmare by nature
of his existence shares a psychic link
with humanity that by destroying
nightmare it basically destroyed
humanity right so it was kind of the
first step
and the chaos king taking everybody out
now those individuals who were sleeping
at the time were out of the picture
right and that just
really thinned the herd for the number
of characters and heroes that could
actually stand against the against the
chaos king which is why when we covered
that story that there were so few heroes
fighting against the chaos king because
everybody was taken out of commission
when nightmare was destroyed but the
next big thing that you saw with this
character
actually came by way of fear itself
which was an amazing story so for those
of you guys who never read fear itself
which is also a story that we have here
on this channel and you'll find both of
these down in the description both
chaos war and fear itself fear itself
was a story where we learned that odin
actually had a third brother
who had basically been imprisoned inside
i think was inside earth and that when
he emerged he basically gave like
everybody hammers right so like
juggernaut got a hammer
and like all these different these
different characters did like i think
the incredible hulk did like it was kind
of nuts right the details on it kind of
escaped me at the moment uh but
the important thing here is that cole
was in effect the asgardian god of fear
and so when he emerged the power he
possessed basically
captured the world in so much fear that
what nightmare did is he in turn sought
to create something called the fear
crown
by basically gathering up all these
different fear energies that existed as
a result of coal basically coming into
existence or at least emerging from his
prison and then seeking to take the
throne of asgard
and rule it for his own now what this
also did is it led to the revitalized
loki also known as kid loki intervening
so something that i want to specify here
is that loki was a character who had
basically sacrificed his life
during the events of siege on asgard
right he'd basically been killed by the
century robert reynolds and so when that
happened
loki was ultimately reborn as kid loki
in an attempt to kind of like
become a better version of himself right
to kind of remake his mistake or
i guess correct his mistakes and to live
a better life which worked for the most
part the kid loki's stories were amazing
right like kid loki was was really
really cool but kid loki
what he ended up realizing is that if
the fear crown was successfully created
by nightmare
the power that nightmare possessed
because the feared crown would amplify
it would lead him to conquering the
world and so what kid loki did alongside
damon hellstrom
and then leah is they traveled around
trying to free people from the influence
of cole's fear
which worked to a degree but ultimately
because of the fact that they realized
they would be unsuccessful
loki tied himself directly to the fear
crown by basically taking all of his
fear energy and giving it to nightmare
which allowed for the creation of the
crown he then in turn went to the other
uh
other fearlords and then told them what
it was that nightmare was trying to do
and because of the fact that the
fearlords are all consistently waging
war against each other for the purpose
of trying to like attain full control of
the earth and dominate the other
fearlord's realms
all the other ones like despair and
dweller and darkness and all those guys
ended up facing off against nightmare
and he was essentially a stalemate until
mephisto intervened and then took the
fear crown right was just like
done right like literally overpowered
all of them took the fear crown and left
right and so following that loki ended
up sacrificing his life in order to
ensure the fear crown could never
actually be recreated again
and then that led to loki being more or
less aged up in marvel comics being uh
being resurrected and brought back in
his current form and for the most part
that's
really what goes on with nightmare up to
that point in time now
one of the coolest things and this is
this is what's going on right now in
marvel comics there's a story going on
right now
that nobody's reading and it's the best
story that nobody's reading called
marvel and it's one of these things
where
a portion of it's drawn by alex ross who
i consider to be the best comic book
artist in the history of the industry
but then you also have like other
stories that are kind of thrown in there
and the whole idea here we don't really
know exactly how it's going to end but
the whole idea here is that nightmare
kind of has this grand scheme and there
is a point where at least at the moment
he's facing off against the combined
forces of galactus and eternity along
with a few other cosmic entities
it's a ridiculously good story that
we're definitely going to cover like we
have to cover it uh in fact we'll
probably start covering it before this
video drops but it's
it's super cool right it's a it's a
really really really really really good
story but nightmare is one of these guys
where like he pops up he does some
things and then he basically leaves and
you don't really
so you don't really see a whole lot of
him i will say that if nightmare really
is the main bad guy
in wand division that you'll see a lot
more of him in marvel comics and that
would probably explain
why he's in marvel in the first place
the the actual marvel storybook uh the
the marvel comic book itself that'll
probably explain why he's there
is because he's gonna have a more
prominent role but again it's one of
these weird things where we don't really
know exactly what's going on in one
division we don't really know
exactly how his character is going to be
involved if he's even going to be
involved at all in the end
only time will tell so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
here
here i am
so
you